and i love this man is he on the phone
i'm waiting actually yeah they're
looking for him he's been running a
little weight okay so i don't know i
mean we've got we got the hard outs and
stuff like that but we do have we do
we're we're we are free at the top of
the next hour yeah we're gonna so dion
is on i'm talking to him is he on right
now here we go okay great is this coach
french you there coach
oh humbleness i really miss my
humbleness
i miss you too did you hear who checked
you in on the phone line who just did
you hear that yes yes maggie d man
that's the man with the plan
[Laughter]
dion
dion will you let me know what that plan
is because i i don't know what that plan
is i have no what are we gonna do to go
viral because every time i i'm on your
show we do something say something to go
viral okay
i don't know um what do you want to talk
about that you think can go viral i got
a remedy for the minority hiring
okay go dion go ahead okay
why are we shooting at coaches
from the african-american point of view
let's go to the top
let's
have expansion rich
let's have expansion of three to four
teams
mandate
there has to be
minority ownership
in these three to four teams
and then yes let it let it falls where
it may
and so
you think that
i i agree with you that that that that
having minority ownership and
um that voice in the room
where decisions get made collectively as
a league
would
essentially you would say trickle down
to seeing more people of color as head
coaches in the league is that what
you're saying rich i can't come into
your house
and tell you to hire a sister
to be your chef
i can't do that that's your house
you can't you can't come into my house
and tell me who to hire
to do my cooking
you're not you're not gonna do that
because it's my house i pay the bills
that that's my thing i heard it
you're not gonna come into the nfl and
tell
32 billionaires what to do
you're not gonna do that
but if you mandate
that
three to four of those are
african-american
let them do what they do
and how about how about this too
how about this dispel the whole notion
of minority practice and you just can't
say well they didn't harm is white
owners 32 white owners not iron black
folks okay cool all right what about the
black folks are they hiring black folks
now we now we're gonna see
we're gonna see what's what
well i mean i don't know i don't even
know if that's a guarantee either right
prime i mean just it's not a guarantee
but at least you would know what's what
what guarantee ain't nothing guaranteed
i mean a few years ago we had several
african-american coaches unfortunately
we
we didn't win
and they were terminated and we thought
we would be replenished but we're not so
instead of crying at the mid-level i
don't cry at the mid-level man i don't i
don't do that
let's make a change at the top let's
fight for that let's not fight for the
middle
and coaching let's fight for the top and
on ship and what about you doing what
you're doing right now dion proving that
you don't what have to
go and coach for 25 years and uh and you
can actually be a former player who gets
a shot in football yeah right yeah
that's the truth i remember having this
conversation with coach george because
he's like friend man i mean coach just
the eddie you're a third leader when you
played for the tennessee
titans you were you were coaching man
you were leading you were helping with
the game plan um you saw things during
the game that you that you told your
coordinators and they made it happen
and you can manage people
you you've got this and he's a
phenomenal coach i talk to him all the
time one of my favorite people
i love him it's so many more guys
several names come to my mind rich that
can
coach and i and i think they plan on
coaching at some level i'm having a camp
um also in june
that's going to bring
a mult multiple many many former nfl
players that wants to get into coaching
and we're going to show them
what's what because often times you just
saying what you think it is man it's
it's it's not only tremendous hours but
you got to understand today's kids and
if you don't love kids you just this is
not the the
the skill
of the career that you should obtain
it's not you don't love kids you forget
dion sanders here on the rich eisen show
we're up against the hard end of an hour
here on our terrestrial radio uh
affiliates so um you're courtesy here of
the new gillette labs razor
with exfoliating bar right you can check
out their activation in santa monica or
go to gillette.com
skate hold on a second i'm 20 seconds to
the end of the the heart out here and
then i got two minutes on the other end
see i i i know you know television and
you know uh communication as well dude
like a shave as quick as watching your
face man
well here's the neat thing about it too
as uh hour number one comes to an end
right here on the rich eisen show got
about a couple more minutes left here
and you could stay through the hour next
hour for dionna if you have time but
it's up to you um so uh that
i remember i when i saw that you were
doing something shaving it made me
reminded me of the story that you told
me you never saw another grown man shave
till you got to college
never right you know i didn't have the
in-house thing so i mandated that i
teach my kids how to shave and uh i'm
thankful because gillette is not just a
company i'm just endorsing rich you know
i got to believe you to endorse you yes
i know it i use on a daily basis and i
taught my kids years ago how to shave
with gillette
so
partnering with them was a easy win for
for both parties to me
um they're wonderful they're phenomenal
they understand um this whole game of
shaving um these new gillette labs
razors with exfoliating part is crazy
unbelievable
personally i like the the razor that
heats up i forget the name of it but
that's the one i like you push the
button rich in the darn thing heat up so
you got a warm shave and it's awesome
man
awesome i love it
i miss you dion every single time i talk
to you
i'm just a family man we're good we're
good i'll be honest with you this is a
home super bowl so i've never covered a
super bowl before while also acting a
parent at the same time
this is new for me yeah i need to know
one thing yes one thing i want to be
honest okay
did you cut
the mattress off susie's back
yes dion we have only three children oh
that's good
yes they are rich
rich rich but you're a man come on man
and you're back to back you're the
cowboys back to back
they're a year and a half apart dion all
three of them rich she didn't even get
out the hospital good when you were back
in
your prime time
get the matches off your back oh my
goodness
wherever she is she's driven off the
road
right now she sends her best to you
prime
[Laughter]
she sends her best team
she's unbelievable she is
she is when you talk about equality as a
wife she brings a lot to the table man
and you guys are awesome man you know
you're one of my heroes man i'm the host
with the most my humble love you prime
we'll have you back on again thanks
again man love you too i remember the
look man the things that we shared on
the network man unbelievable man i
missed the heck at you man right back at
you and i love what you're doing coach
prime thanks for the call
take care that's the one and only dion
sanders
oh my god
[Laughter]
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here